what is going on there reject nation we
are gonna check out today the season
three premiere of brooklyn nine nine
before we go into that i wanna give a
special thank you to a sponsor that i
personally sought out because i use
their products every day i see other
people shine them out i'm like well i
want to work them since i use them all
the time hello fresh because guys
everybody's got to eat but it can be
challenging figuring out what to eat
assembling the ingredients that's where
hellofresh can save you a whole bunch of
time and money i mean this sincerely
they offer a huge variety of quick easy
and delicious recipes farm sourced
pre-portioned and delivered to your door
at peak freshness very convenient they
provide fit and wholesome recipes for
the whole family including you
pescetarian and vegetarian peeps out
there they'll help you cut down on food
waste and trips to the grocery store all
while keeping your diet interesting and
delicious we've literally been eating
their food for months already so i'm
proud that they are sponsoring this
video so you can use our special link in
the description box or go to
hellofresh.com and use this really fun
code pog reel r16 p-o-g-r-e-e-l-r-16
for up to 16 free meals plus three
surprise gifts across six hello fresh
boxes plus free shipping now that is a
tasty deal let's chop it to some
youtubes
[Music]
that's a welcome surprise new commanding
officer captain seth dozerman my motto
is simple efficiency efficiency
efficiency could probably just say it
once
oh no i live my life by numbers you see
this watch it tells me how many calories
i burn at any time question how many
calories you think i burned walking from
there to there you female closest to me
i need you morons to work eight times
harder than you've ever worked and your
entire life
i'm having a heart attack
okay
get a doctor oh god that was that was a
force of nature just then do you guys
know that andy sambrick and bill hader
premiered on snl the same day what
apparently the new captain survived and
his heart attack not the craziest thing
that happened at the precinct today
we kissed
like three hours ago
yes
what do we start dating and it makes
things weird at work so let's just
keep it light and breezy let's not tell
anyone so we can figure out what this is
first smort rule number two let's not
put labels on it we're not boyfriend and
girlfriend we're just
mermseep and jinglebin
let's not have sex right away
quick crap rule crap rule
should we go out tonight yeah totally
maybe eight maybe nine doesn't matter
we're light and breezy totally light and
breezy
[Applause]
could be a while raymond they're trying
to come up with a name for the nypd's
new pigeon mascot
oh no
[Music]
hmm
how long could that possibly take
they've been at it for months
the doctors have informed me that i have
a genetic heart condition which um
lowers my life expectancy from 103 to
64.
say goodbye to the fun hilarious
laid-back seth dozerman that you used to
love
boys hand them out
the hell are these what the hell are
these
[Laughter]
countdown clock to remind you to
complete a task every 55 minutes what
happens when the clock runs out
failure failure you are behind schedule
ah i'm not a toddler this is stupid i
know you're not a toddler keep that
dozer path on you at all times fine
but i am gonna play the hell out of some
backgammon
thanksgiving good at backhand
no free soda refills
jakey's going on a date
are you going on a date with amy what no
why uh because you guys just kissed on
that mission
not that it's any of your business boyle
but the person that i'm taking on a date
is a girl from the gym what why is this
the first time i'm hearing about her
or that you go to the gym
yeah you knew that was coming nobody
wants you turning into another terry ugh
hey
people like the way that i look sure
they do big guy
it's never gonna happen boyle okay
because i find amy repulsive and she
finds me extremely handsome
i haven't even begun to pressure you two
i've already written my best man's
speech for your wedding
oh i'm gonna need you to get married on
a farm a lot of my jokes rely on that
all right
officially on a date romantical date
yes we are romantical you got a haircut
it looks nice oh thanks
you also got a haircut
at some point in your life i'm sure
that's not your baby hair that would be
crazy i think i've been on this date how
do we make it not weird i know
let's just get super drunk yes great
idea pardon me ma'am could you please
bring us four kamikaze shots and four
for me as well no for drinking we can do
this we're back on track we're keeping
it light and breezy
so
i hope it wasn't a mistake
hope it wasn't a mistake title your sex
tape
title of our sex tape
yes did you french boyle i'm not gonna
answer that and no one over the age of
12 says french oh that's a yes oh my god
you had sex oh i could tell because
you're glowing
dozerman says he wants to see you
captain
[Applause]
according to your dozer pad four of your
co-workers have been gathered around
your desk the last 90 seconds i wanted
to get more work done but all they
wanted to do was talk about my dating
life you know my motto sir
chose before hoes
chose his chores
i like you
i could tell from the moment i walked in
here that we were one in the same
detail-oriented love crunching numbers
bet your apartment's immaculate probably
eat off the floor and i do yeah
i'm gonna handle this for you oh god
send out a dozerblast
oh no
hey everyone stop talking about
peralta's personal life
dozerblast over oh those would be worse
yeah
this has been a dozer blast i saw what
you did
been working on picking a name for the
pigeon mascot for uh
several months now i feel like you might
need a breather
i thing is so scary
nation on community engagement we'll get
to your presentation raymond it's on the
agenda
it says here it's scheduled quote after
everyone leaves unquote and not a minute
later
damn it
with all due respect that pigeon is
clearly a rayjay
hi
gina linetti the human form of the 100
emoji
[Laughter]
absolutely name the pigeon raymond you
can't make me i can make you and i will
name the pigeon that's an order
paulie
thank you
was that so hard
and breezy if we want to break rules
break rules like what's another rule we
could break
no making out at work no
unknown environment
what's that noise
i don't hear anything warning unknown
environment unknown environment
[Laughter]
unknown environment
i had it on my desk but i kept spilling
coffee on it
oops tamper alert come on diaz
you two have been in this evidence hello
so i guess it is hoes before it chose
with you friend now i understand why
nothing gets done in this precinct the
detectives are too busy frenching with
each other
because as long as i'm here you two are
done and i'm gonna be here a long long
long long long long long long
yep
this right here this is a heart attack
oh it's a big one
oh goodness
it's all right we're getting help
tell my wife
that i love her
work ethic
[Laughter]
oh
oh my god
can you think of anything that may have
caused dozerman to be stopped he might
have been startled by how far apart we
were standing that seems unlikely do me
a favor and pull the surveillance ticket
no
because this is a police precinct you
two have something to tell me
all right fine
detective santiago and i may have been
in there
snorking
yes
i need to know how to make fun of you
you guys dating no oh that's not good i
mean yes i just said no because of the
rules we said we weren't going to tell
anyone it's very new and we're still
figuring it out yeah
look terry loves love
[Laughter]
terry's a love bug as your commanding
officer
i am very disappointed in both of you
hmm let's go look at the surveillance
tapes yeah
oh absolutely
our feud is getting in the way of the
nypd's business madeline the pr
department is a joke the work here is
meaningless nine weeks to choose the
name paulie i know instantly it should
be pepper officer peppero pigeon maybe
we should start the whole naming process
you're wasting my talents this man is a
timber lake and you need to stop
treating him like a fatone yes yes
perhaps you're right solid in sync
comparison
i think we found the perfect person to
wear the pants i knew it yeah it's you
raymond you are 43 minutes behind i know
get off my back computer go look
i'm following our captain's orders his
orders were stupid i hated him more than
any cop i've ever known
whoa
i just realized i'm never gonna be able
to say that to his face i mean i could
say to his wife at the funeral but it
won't be the same
[Laughter]
i'm just trying to keep this place
running that's my job
keith's clear how you like me now sucker
i mean
i hope you found peace
terry loves peace rules have been broken
and nothing bad happened nothing bad
happened terry yelled at us and we
killed our captain
jake
is this a bad idea no
what do you want to do then
go back to being colleagues
yeah maybe that's what it needs to be
right now
okay
okay
what a crock of [ __ ] no no no no no no
no no boyle can we please just go to
dinner no no no no no this is not how
you and amy are supposed to end you're
supposed to grow old and die holding
each other as your cruise ship slowly
takes on water
[Laughter]
we kept it light and breezy light and
breezy
ow bright and breezy is how you describe
a linen pants suit
what do i do tell me easy you march over
there you tell her how you feel and you
bring a fancy bottle of lavender shampoo
because champagne woman's head is the
most erotic thing you could ever no uh
oh
sorry sorry that's okay
i was home and i really wanted to talk
to someone about us and dozerman and
about hope being gone and
then i realized that the only person i
want to talk about that stuff with is
you oh yeah that's what i'm talking
about talk screw just being colleagues
and screw light and breezy
right
definitely
i really did it
oh charles is here big time
no
i quit no i did not follow you to pr to
watch you quit i followed you because
you're great and i figured pr would be
the easiest path to launching my reality
show lynnetti set go
the audience show was to be called gina
in a bottle no that was not fragrance
line
keep up a plus
even if the only people listening are a
bunch of second graders because captain
raymond holt
never
gives up inspiring words
i'm going to give that speech help me
with that pigeon head never give up
never surrender
rosa diaz you are six hours ahead of
schedule
whoa damn that's the first time i've
seen him smile i didn't do it for him i
did it cause it's my job
we cool
we're cool
good
damn girl new captain will be here today
now i don't know who once you're sending
us
but it doesn't matter
because we're a family oh no
is it the vulture oh no oh no
[Music]
i'm your new captain the vulture
i know we have our history me vulturing
your cases
me telling you to eat my farts that's
all in the past cause now that i run
this precinct things are gonna get much
much
worse
so suck it
[Laughter]
oh yeah oh man uh good good times [ __ ]
happens man
[ __ ] happens [ __ ] happens please john go
go take it away john of course well i
mean if there's one thing i've learned
from this episode it's that clearly we
need our own mascot we don't have a
mascot
and i feel like that is the key to
bringing this channel to the whole other
level
i mean think about it it could be like a
big film a big foam film reel with like
a you know anthropomorphized face on the
front you know call it uh call it
ronaldo the real or uh
robbie reals or uh you know
uh freddy film can or uh
uh
chip celluloid or
uh
you know uh uh
uh daguerreotype jones
uh
yeah
i'm gonna just cut you off right i was
about to hurt myself
i do not like this idea no no mascot um
i will not even engage in a humorous yes
and jest with you about this right now
all right
are you in fact i find this whole
idea of yours kind of repulsive and i
never want you to bring it up here in
this room ever again or
even remind me that it exists in this
video now yes of course not of course
not you can you can make your own little
ipad thing for me
with your face on it
and a countdown i'm gonna need you to
stop coming up with ideas yes i am all
ears sir
what did i think of the episode
tell me
that's not an idea that's an opinion
there's a difference please oh tell us
what you thought of the episode i had a
blast with this episode i think they did
very wisely to have a good
amount of they know they know we know
that eventually i assume captain holt
will be back so i love that they got
bill hader that's a face you're not
going to be upset to see and especially
they've got him standing there in that
one scene going i will be here a very
very very long time
obviously you know that's not true and
then to one up that with the vulture is
is a wonderful game i really loved that
game
uh just you know from where the
cliffhanger left us off it's also cool
to have the start of the season take
place even though in real time it was
like months later
only three hours later so it feels
authentically like just pick back up
and uh amy and jake really endearing
even though it's like a pretty standard
workplace thing to have like oh we gotta
keep this a secret and ah it's gonna be
so awkward and ah we're we're sneaking
around and eventually get caught i
thought they did a very very charming
iteration of that and the chemistry was
there man the chemistry was lovely and
funny
and i was rooting for them as much as i
was laughing at them
well i'm glad you liked the episode man
thank you i am glad you're glad
i am
yeah yeah
there's some solid opinions you got
there john
the
the whole thing with amy and jake i feel
like
it has the potential to implode on them
though
there's a lot there that they definitely
have to work through they both have a
fear of trust
they have a fear of connection and as
much as they open themselves up you
could see some things some warning signs
here the fact that they needed to get
belligerently drunk in order to bond
with each other on their first date i
understand awkward friends are so long
you gotta work past some barriers it's
not the same as being casual then
hooking up
you gotta
find ways to truly be intimate with each
other hell they even
temporarily decided maybe we shouldn't
see each other anymore
only to come back i could see an on and
off again situation but ultimately
resulted in them getting married maybe
having a kid down the road
but
there's a lot they're gonna have to
learn along the way
it was entertaining and amusing
second thought
holt doing what he's doing at the pr
relation team
that much is a [ __ ]
i love seeing her on her she's a series
regular yet they should make her one
they should because she is a great foil
to the hult train
machine it's that's what i'm curious to
see is they can actually make the pr
team an interesting part of the show if
they can successfully do that
where you get to kind of know some of
the pr team and then you get to see him
actually make the pr team even better at
its job
then we got some television magic right
there happening for us sprinkle some new
personalities into the cast on a
recurring basis that'd be cool a vulture
bossing them around is a really good
cliffhanger to be had
and yeah it's really entertaining
the part that i missed
when i'm watching this it kind of flew
over my head i didn't realize that rosa
had upset terry so much to the point
that she needed to prove herself
on her job and then like over deliver
on her tasks for the day
i was like oh
she really felt like she had to
show
a sign of good will
with him
i'm like
i don't recall him
being like
super upset with you i thought you were
kind of just doing your rose the thing
and he got
a little bit annoyed yeah
but it looked like you guys had some
serious conflict like was there a scene
cut out of this is there a
b plot that this could have taken up in
a whole other episode of yeah them
having to make an amends by the end or
something like that yeah
when she was like
we get something it was like a moment
they had
and i didn't the setup to the moment
they had
was like oh you mean when she put the
thing in the ceiling and he got annoyed
and then they kind of like jabbed at him
about the how he was obsessive with
it was more like a weird terry problem
that he was having about structure and
such
terry does love structure terry loves
structure
so yeah i thought that was a really
funny
funny episode
a lot of humor and heart to be had boyle
being the worst kind of annoying friend
you could have in a situation like this
not too exposed but also the best kind
of friend you could ask for
it gets you back on the right track it's
you back on the right goddamn track what
more can you ask for these days
and that pigeon's freaky
that is a scary pigeon i do love i did
it was a directorial choice i
appreciated that they kept putting it in
places where it would look like michael
myers just standing and staring in the
back
yeah it was creepy as [ __ ] yeah it's
good good creepy pigeon yeah peppero
pigeon is really a better name too so i
hope that i hope that gets
changed
in future
episodes good gina
good gene in this episode too
and yeah but a pee with the with the
pigeon in would be the best way to go
about it
polly the pigeon pepper the pigeon
percival pigeon percival that is a good
name thanks percival the pitch that is
actually really catchy that would have
really worked it's a unique name you
know but it catches it's not too hard
not to catch in your mind
philip
ooh
call him philly page for short
philly p like philly d
who's philly d phillip defranc sxe phil
philip
beautiful bastards i love your faces and
i'll see you tomorrow
you've just been filled you know remix
those in the right order in there
there's your reference there's your
comedy reference
to the youtube channel
[Music]
how about
patron pigeon
pandemic pigeon
you i know you told me not to bring this
up in the earlier part of the video but
pandemic i think you will be the perfect
mascot for this channel costume or no
because you're such a lovely person
you have such a beautiful warm smile and
i feel like you could bring that energy
as a force of good will here pandemic
pigeon polly pit see they name the
pigeon polly your name is paul you could
be paulie but not polly like you know
like a parrot polly you could be like
hey paulie you know like in new york
it's perfect for you dude so hey get
those measurements going we'll we'll
send you some some ideas of how to
stitch the costume together and i expect
to see some headshots in our inbox
within the week all right buddy can you
do that
and if you do that give me an extra
special shout out next month but anyhow
hope you're doing well happy march it's
been two years since the world shut down
and if there's anything that opens me up
to you buddy so take care and we'll see
you soon
all the love
[Music]